بطوله استراليا المفتوحه هي واحده من اهم
اربع بطولات في التنس المعروفين بالغرام
اسلام وخلال السنتين الماضيتين جالس بيصير
جدل حوالينا بيخلي الاهتمام فيها يتضاعفوا
يتجاوز متابعي ومحبي التنس حول العالم
البطوله انطلقت من يومين ومن وقتها
شايفينها ساحه منى
لكن للاسف موسي رجال رياضي او تنافس في
اللعبه الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه مسجل
نفسها حاضره بقوه في البطوله ومشاركه اكثر
من لاعب اساسي يعني كانها القصه بدات طبعا
لما سفير اوكرانيا في استراليا انشر صوره
بتظهر العالم الروسي في مدرجات المشجعين
واذان واستنكر رفع العلم الروسي وطالب
الاتحاد الاسترالي بتطبيق قاعده العلم
المحايد فورا العالم كان موجود في مباراه
اللاعب الاوكرانيه كاترينا بدل امام
اللاعبه الروسيه كامله
رهيبه وبالمناسبه مشاهدينا بطوله استرا
المفتوحه مثل الموضوع البطولات والرياضات
مؤخرا سامحه للاعبي روسيا وبيلا روسيا انه
بيلعبوا ولكن تحت علم محايد ودون تمثيل
وطني او تمثيل لبلادهم او حتى وحتى في
المباريات جنب اسمهم بينحط علم ابيض على
عكس باجيب اللاعبين اللي بينحط جنب
اسمائهم اعلام بلادهم يعني بعد الاحتجاج
الاوكراني هذا الاتحاد الاسترالي لاسترجاب
وطلع بيان قال فيه صحيح كنا سامحين بحمل
الاعلام الروسيه الروسيه لكن اذا ما سبب
استخدامها ازعاج ولكننا الان مضطرين اننا
نمنعها السفاره الروسيه ردت على القرار
وصفته بالمؤسف والتلاعب السياسي وقالت
اللي صاير في لاعبين واجبارهم على اللعب
على محايد لا كمان تبغوا حتى الجمهور ما
يعرف يشجعهم هذه مو هي الواقعه الوحيده
اللي حرب روسيا اوكرانيا سجلت فيها حضوره
في استراليا المفتوحه السنه ففي لاعبه
اوكرانيه اسمها مارتا كوستوك وهي
الخامسه عالميا رفضت مصافحه خصمها في
المباراه فيكتوريا ازارينكا لانها من
بيلاروسيا وقالت انها ما راح تصافح اي
لاعب روسيه او بيروسيا الا لو كانوا من
اللي اذان الحرب بوضوح وكان سبق ولها نفس
الموقف في بطوله امريكا المفتوحه في 20 22
ووقتها تصدرت العناوين على العموم هذه مو
اول مره بنشوف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
داخله في الرياضه السنه الماضيه تحديدا في
التنس ايضا بطوله الشهيره رفضت للرسول
بالروسيين تماما انهم يشاركوا في البطوله
ورابطه تنسى العالميه احتجت وحرمه البطوله
من احتساب نقاطها في التصنيف العالمي
وشوفنا فيك كاس العالم لكره القدم كيف
استبعدت روسيا ودخلت مكانها بولندا كثير
ناس شايفه اللي بيصير اسلوب ضغط على روسيا
وبالله روسيا يعني وانه مش دي مفيد لكن
كمان في كثير ناس معترضين وشايفين الموضوع
جالس يخرب رياضه المفروض تكون بعيده
نتكلم في هذا الموضوع اكثر مع ضيفنا اللي
بينضم الينا المحلل الرياضي حسن دراز اهلا
فيك معنا حسن خليني في البدايه اسالك بما
انه في اصلا انقسام في هذا الموضوع خليني
اعرف منك انت بتميل لي اي جهه او وجهه نظر
وكراده
لازم تفصل عند السياسه لان دي كانت
الرساله
ملعب كره القدم
كويسه
الامور بقت داخله في الرياضه بشكل كبير
جدا
لكن حتى في كره القدم دلوقت ممنوع من
اللاعبين مثلا في الدوري الروسي او في
الدوري المصري دلوقتي وهما بيلعبوا هما
ينتقلوا بالفلوس الى الدورات الاخرى في
الجروب او في العالم كله اللاعيبه اللي
موجوده في الكاميرات دي ممكن انها كمان
تقدر
الامور بقت مؤثره بشكل كبير جدا في مساله
الرياضه
رفضت تسلم على اللاعبه الاخرى دائما في
موضوع التنسي يعني خصوصا تتنس تحديدا
كرياضه دائما الكلام فيها عن الاخلاق
والاخلاقيات اللعب وهكذا وهذا الموضوع
طبعا كله في الرياضه بشكل عام يعني بس انه
في التنس بشكل اكبر هل هذا يعتبر خرق
للقواعد ولا لا انه من حقها او لانه
اوكرانيه بيمرروا لها
او اهم
تحدي
التنافس بشكل
رساله لان ايا كان اللي بيحصل بيكون في
تنائهم بيكون فيه رساله مميزه
هل سببه شفنا هذا الموقف الان اللي بيصير
مع روسيا وبالروسيا هل سبق وشوفنا صار قبل
كده في الرياضه ضد اي دوله بسبب اي اي سبب
اخر ايضا سياسي
لكن اعتقد في كره القدم
25 25
حاليا في كلام كل المسافر ده الكبيره زي
دي
المواصفات
في العالم
هيكون في قواعد القوانين عشان لو حصل اي
مشكله
من الرياضه او نقدر نعمل العقوبات معينه
وان اي دوله
يعني يصير في هذا النقاش وكذا بس ما نحن
شايفين من المتحكمه الان يعني شفنا في كاس
العالم شفنا في البطولات دي يعني
ممكن ممكن
صديقي
الروسيه على اوكرانيا طب يعني هذه بلده في
نهايه اليوم ومو ضروري وهو ياخذ موقف
مناسب لك يعني
تحديدا شويه الاخرى ان يكون في خاصه في
مساله الرياضه في السياسه ان يكون فيه حل
مهم جدا بحيث يضمن الربيع حتى هم
الاعلاميه وشروطه حتى السوشيال ميديا قدام
الجمهور طيب نحنا بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
وهذه التوضيحات كان معنا المحلل الرياضي
حسن دراس شكرا لك يا حسن
[موسيقى]